welcome back to Las Vegas now in today's
legal minute we are learning what are
the main reasons immigration cases are
lost Eric Palacios from Eric Palacios
and Associates the sponsor of this
segment tell us more
hi I'm Eric Palacios welcome to the
legal minute the question of the week is
what are the main reasons immigration
cases are lost
number one lack of documentation
immigration cases often require
extensive documentation such as proof of
identity employment history and family
ties if the necessary documentation is
missing or insufficient it can result in
you losing your case number two
inadequate representation not having
adequate legal representation not having
a good attorney can negatively impact
your chances of success in an
immigration case number three changing
immigration loss immigration laws are
complex and constantly changing which
can make it difficult for individuals to
navigate the process on their own if you
don't understand the laws and
regulations or don't present your case
in the best manner it can lead to losing
your case and maybe even your
deportation if you have immigration
questions it's best to talk to an
immigration attorney right away
give Eric Palacios and Associates a call
at 702-444-7777